- It is time
(Andrew laughs)
to own up to our obsessions, weird or not.
For the first time in
our New York City studio,
I love being here.
(audience and guest cheering)
I'm gonna hit this button
and a topic will be selected
by our super random, super computer,
which apparently followed us from L.A.
(guests and audience laugh)
Then the person obsessed with the topic
will own up and sell
us on their obsession.
I will get us started.
Here we go.
(button dings)
Okay.
(bell dinging)
(Kelly gasps)
- [Andrew] Oh.
(crowd anticipation)
- I'm out.
- I share this obsession.
- You!?
(audience laughs)
- Are we gonna do it next season?
You wanna do one? You wanna do one?
- I will happily be in your fantasy pool.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
Oh my gosh. We should do it.
It's my first season, I'm obsessed.
Lester happened to kick my
behind this last weekend.
- [Andrew] Oh.
- [Josh] That's okay.
- [Kelly] But
- [Josh] So plenty of time.
- I didn't really know
the players as well,
and now I'm obsessed.
Now I'm like watching games
- [Josh] Yep.
- That were on weeks ago just to study up.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
You're really, you're going deep.
I'm really into it because I
like a game you see, Andrew.
- [Andrew] Wow.
- Yeah.
And fantasy football's fun.
- He keeps trying to get me
to watch the sports ball.
- I will literally,
- [Kelly] Sports ball.
- I'll be on Sundays,
where our show starts at three,
I'll be backstage watching
on my iPad, football games.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- And Andrew will walk by and go,
you watching sports ball again?
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- I couldn't do it this year
- [Andrew] Wow.
- because I'm so committed to work.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah, you're very focused.
- And so I have it-
- You're very focused.
- [Kelly] Well, I am not
committed to work and I
was like, I'm doing it.
- Yeah.
- I'll play your fantasy game.
- Will you play? Perfect.
- Let's, yes!
It's so fun if you like a game.